I'm here with Lilly Singh they literally
say oh we are here tonight celebrating
kids what's the what was the best part
about being a kid whoa I think being
fearless you know when I was a kid I
would try skateboarding I would jump off
myself I would do all types of tricks
and now I'm terrified to do anything I
walk up the stairs another find a
stretch all right next question
the Kids Choice Awards is all about
slime how have you prepared to get
slimed
oh I haven't if that happens I will be
thoroughly shocked and I bet you look
for this hair and makeup so be kind all
right some groundbreaking news was
recently announced you're getting your
own late-night TV oh my god yes I am I'm
very excited I mean it's pretty it is
groundbreaking I'm really proud of
myself and I just hope I do it justice
I'm excited to get into it okay are you
gonna be on my show Oh what can we see
on your show you hopefully hopefully by
all my faves hopefully Dwayne Johnson
opposite of Gomez I just want to
interview amazing people doing amazing
things this is long list
I mean I'm available have you consulted
any other late night stars to get any
advice I did actually so I talked to her
Solomon oz she was a really good
presence on a late night show I also
talked to Jimmy Fallon obviously Jimmy
Fallon's been so supportive through my
whole journey so he gave me a lot of
great advice
shout out to Jimmy I love you we love
you okay hold on wait pause for a second
is that Baus lipstick you know what I
adore you it is not a brand my bed but
it is very similar to Bob okay guys
thank you so much badge